Oh
you
well it's hard to know what to add to a
terrific session from which I learned a
lot but it occurs to me from a
management point of view that what's
critical the humanistic management is
what i would call humanistic hiring it's
very hard to change people and if you're
not hiring people into your organization
who treat each other in the right way
who care about other people as human
beings who bring more than basic
technical skills to the party and if you
don't promote people who show more than
basic technical and performance
competence you're not going to have a
humanistic organization it starts at the
beginning and unless you get the hiring
write speeches rewards Kratos really
won't make that much difference I think
there are at least two important
ingredients to developing an ethically
healthy organization or what I might
call a healthy organizational ethical
culture one is accountability that every
particular person in the company needs
to understand that they are accountable
for their actions but also they're
accountable in terms of making sure
others are living up to the values of
that organization the second perhaps
most important element in developing an
ethical culture is what i would call
critical reflection there are group
decisions that are made all the time
within organizations but unless that
organization has those groups meet after
the action has occurred and critically
reflect upon what was accomplished how
it could have been done better and to
think it through from a reflective point
of view then I don't think that culture
can be said to have an ethically
a healthy culture so what does it take
to develop an ethically healthy
organization from my perspective if we
don't understand how the value and
vulnerability of of each of us which is
in my vocabulary is all about
understanding that we all have dignity
we all have this inherent god-given
birthright and that we're all valuable
and we're all vulnerable at the same
time and in a workplace this manifests
itself so so deeply in the sense that
when people are together in an
organization they want to be seen they
want to be heard they want to be
recognized and in essence they want to
be treated as if they are something of
value and something of work and so
recognizing that I think is probably
fundamental but there's another piece in
it that is really important from my
perspective which is that if the
leadership of these of an organization
is not completely on board and
completely signed on to the importance
of honoring dignity inside not only just
inside the company but also honoring
dignity of their customers honoring
dignity of everyone in the in the supply
chain I think the the chances of the
organization developing a dignity
culture are pretty slim so the
leadership has to be on board I've seen
it time and time again I've seen both
I've seen where the organization wants
to create a culture of dignity where
everybody's treated well but the
leadership doesn't and that's where the
failures happen but I've seen many
examples of when the leadership says you
know what this is really our high
priority we want everyone here in this
company to feel valued to feel cared for
and to feel like they're making a
significant contribution to the
well-being of the company and to the
profitability of the
company well so what is the most a one
thing that one can do to create a more
healthy ethical organization from a
humanistic perspective I would say it's
really very simple to simply engage the
people that you work with that you sell
to that you supply from really your
stakeholders in some meaningful way in a
discourse where you listen and where
they feel empowered that's when they
feel the dignities and some were
inherently protected that's when Trust
gets built and that's when you typically
get information about what is the right
thing to do so you build healthier
organizations simply through talking
with people and listening to them in a
mindful way without preconceived notions
about how they can be useful to you but
also how you as an organization or a
manner can be useful to them in a mutual
giving and taking a manner so I think
there are lots of things that go into
creating an ethically healthy
organization and they're clearly certain
things that you can't have in place to
create an ethically organization healthy
organization so for example if the
leadership is not ethically grounded
that's certainly a problem if people
don't have a clear sense the purpose of
the organization it's clearly a problem
but I think that probably the most
important thing to keep in mind is to
ensure that the people in the
organization feel that their
contributions are valued that they're
being listened to that they're being
recognized for their work and the reason
I say that is that if people don't feel
recognized if they don't feel that
they're being listened to if they don't
feel feel that their work is being
valued then it becomes very difficult to
have a sense that what the organization
doing is somehow worthwhile and worth
pursuing and supporting and when that
feeling is lost and I think that opens
up the possibility
for a lots of unhealthy and unethical
behaviors in the context of the
organization so what's the most
important key to developing ethically
healthy organizations I think there's at
least two components first there has to
be a very clear statement by the
organization what its purposes and
values are I think it's a very soft
thing to consider but I think it's
incredibly important for getting into
everyone's mind around the organization
you know what our standards what our
objectives you know what are the things
I can be held accountable to what are
the things i can hold other people
accountable to and a statement it could
be that simple a statement of values
gets everyone on the same page i think
creates a common framework then the
second question I think is much more
difficult question which is how do you
actually credibly enforce how do you
credibly disseminate and incredibly
organized the organization to live up to
these values some of this can be very
mundane and as simple as how do we
account for things how do we allow
people to cooperate you know how do we
coordinate actions second you know if
people don't live up what's the
procedures for trying to remedy that
this can be informal but as long as
there are there are some structures
where people understand not only these
are our values and these are what we're
about but I actually think the
organization can help us realize those
and when we deviate there's someone I
can talk to I can blow the whistle or I
can talk to someone informally or I can
you know have some response it's going
to go up the chain and things are
actually going to change the end of the
day so I think those two components a
clear sense of mission in an
organization and the actual structures
that organizationally allow that mission
to be implemented well if the question
is how to get a better organization
basically healthy organization I guess
that as a professor of management is the
matter of being a good manager if that's
your responsibility so when teaching in
my classes of management I would say you
can be a manager out of fear so making
people feel a fret of you being the
manager or you just can have people
around that they really realize that you
care about them so good monitor is
someone who care about people cares
about people and it's not a kind
of 19 it's just that you really love
your work a seminar and people will
realize that you love them and it sounds
like this is management yes you love
that in the sense that you want them to
flourish as human beings well when you
are in that company that specific
company so you as manager will take the
best you can from everyone to be sure to
offer to society so if you're working in
my company I want you to be the best
employee for the best good of society
the contribution to come on good in that
says will be possible if people really
realize in your company that you're
teaching them helping them to give to be
of value for society
you